on the Italian coast colored houses
spill down a hillside soaking up the Sun
as they face the sea but look closely
and you notice something's a little
strange in tomoow glee the art of
Illusion is everywhere this fishing
village near Genoa is a living museum of
trompe l'oeil literally to trick the eye
and it does get tricky windows open in
solid walls elaborate stonework that
isn't and while some flowers fade others
stay fresh for years
Comeau Glee's fisherman originally
painted their houses in bright colors
and unusual design so they could
recognize them from the water in the
18th century however it became a way to
make small simple buildings seem
luxurious and grand there are thousands
of trompe l'oeil houses in this region
but only a handful of artists still
painting them
Rafaela strata learned painting from her
grandmother using classical methods on
her own modern designs
she gives house painting a whole new
meaning shot the painted these painted
facades are typical of Liguria really
typical but for a while it seemed like
no one was doing them anymore it's taken
20 years to perfect her technique of
recreating stone so that it looks real
even from close up like most painters
she learned trompe l'oeil from other
artists not in school but with few
artists there are fewer teachers and
fewer places to learn karlip ära has
made a business out of making the
surreal real buyers for his imaginary
terraces and bogus balconies often live
in small houses or city apartments
Perry's job is to improve the view
coconut rum ploy means bringing Milan to
the sea or the seed of the mountains or
vice versa
today's technique comes out of an art
handbook from the 14th century even his
paints have the stamp of history he uses
only pure pigments mixed by hand
it keeps tradition alive and Comeau Glee
the local culture is still in plain view
from the bay to the bar you just might
not believe your eyes